[Musik]
die fortsetzung folgt redaktion dsf
zeigt immer wieder porträt von chips
unsere laborsituation oder vor wichtigen
weichenstellungen
immer wieder bringt der cabral
langzeitbeobachtung wo manche über
längeren zeitraum mit der kamera
begleitet werden christoph gut hat der
simon federer wohl nichts 186 down
syndrom oft froh ist über einen zeitraum
von zwei jahren immer wieder treffer
rituelle wissen was für chancen hätte
hätte sie worte und auch umgesetzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
simon an seinem zwanzigsten geburtstag
wir schreiben das jahr 2006 pausenlos
klingelt die türglocke alle wollen ihnen
gratulieren
simon wohnt bei seinen eltern in
ennetbaden über 70 personen kommen zum
großen fest
auch mich hat simon eingeladen
seit 14 jahre alt war kenne ich ihn
immer wieder habe ich ihn mit der kamera
begleitet seine geschichte wurde zu
einer filmischen langzeitstudie
kennengelernt habe ich dabei auch sein
umfeld seine vielen freunde
ich drücke
[Musik]
seine geschwister léa und jonas sowie
vater und mutter irmgard federer
mit dem down syndrom kommt sie 1986 auf
die welt kinder mit down-syndrom
besuchen in der regel sonderschulen und
geschützte werkstätten nicht so simon
als einer der ersten in der schweiz ging
er einen anderen weg wie kam es dazu
[Musik]
1996 begegne ich ihn zum ersten mal
er ist zehnjährig in seiner umgebung zu
sein es nicht bedrückend
im gegenteil simon hat eine offene art
und ist meist gut gelaunt das down
syndrom oder trisomie 21 ist
zurückzuführen auf ein zusätzliches
chromosom und kommt in allen ländern und
gesellschaftsschichten vor ein kind mit
down syndrom zu bekommen ist für die
eltern meist schwierig ja nicht wirklich
1 800 stellen und tasche ganz
schmerzhaft oder ihre ziemlich planlos
ca katrin zeller ich bin seine mutter
holt sie hat fehler gemacht und
eigentlich
und irgendwie schwierigkeiten sich so
wie sie sind
mit einem solchen kind stellen sich
viele fragen
auch für seine eltern welches heben soll
unser sohn führen wo soll er in die
schule gehen
was heißt das für uns
hier hätte simon hingehört wenn alles in
geordneten bahnen gelaufen wäre
in die heilpädagogische sonderschule
wird ihnen
als er mit seiner mutter auf besuch war
fühlte er sich aber nicht wohl wollte
raus wir sehen uns eltern ein zeichen
eine andere lösung zu suchen
[Musik]
simon wollte in die öffentliche schule
wie alle anderen kinder auch dank der
initiative seine eltern eltern von
simons kollegen und lehrern entstand so
in der primarschule ennetbaden ein
lokales pilotprojekt die
integrationsklasse mittagspause heute
geht sie mal nicht nach hause sondern zu
einer schulkameradin essen
so kommen auch andere eltern mit simon
in kontakt und sie habe unter der besuch
im hallenbad ist ganz nach simons
geschmack schwimmen kann er besser als
viele kinder in seinem alter die
integration in die regelklasse scheint
ein erfolg zu sein simon entwickelt sich
erfreulich kann seine fähigkeiten in
vielen bereichen merklich verbessern
sprachlich wie motorisch
[Musik]
alles sehr schnell ich schwimme feucht
schnell wie er so schnell wie die
anderen um für ein wasserfall ganz viel
gutmachen
1998 kommt es zum bruch
simon darf nicht mehr in die öffentliche
schule die schulpflege lehnt eine
weiterführung des integrationsprojekts
in der oberstufe ab simons eltern sind
beide ärzte mit hochdruck suchen sie
nach einer lösung medizinische
überlegungen stehen dabei nicht im
vordergrund
ihnen geht es einzig und allein um das
wohlergehen ihres sohnes immerhin haben
sie die materielle sicherheit sich auf
die ungewisse situation einlassen zu
können
finanziell ist der größere teil schafft
große satz von assange muss leichter
also will man nicht machen
vor der schule oder vom staat
integration für das kinder warten wenn
wir nicht parat im grünen bereich sind
deren integration im kleinen bereich das
heißt offen sein für einen
unkonventionellen weg
simon es denn keine schule mehr
eingebunden in die heilpädagogische
sonderschule aber wille auch nicht gehen
eine übergangslösung sorgt jetzt dafür
dass er den anschluss nicht verliert
ich hoffe
doch
[Musik]
seine schulbildung hängt jetzt an einem
dünnen faden mit dem zug fährt er herum
durch den ganzen kanton aargau immer
dorthin wo ihr ein paar stunden
schulunterricht bekommen kann
immerhin fördert dies eine
selbstständigkeit
[Musik]
b
heute ist er zu gast in der realschule
rothrist hier unterrichtet die
aushilfslehrer dieter dubach er kennt
simon schon lange und versucht ihn auf
seine weise zu integrieren
simon misst das schulzimmer aus auch du
warst frau kümmert sich um ihn
sie übernimmt den part der stütz
lehrerin unentgeltlich weil sie an das
konzept der integration glaubt
[Musik]
hier hat kritik gehöre zu heiß ich höre
die äußerung als ich meinte schultze
immer hier weil wir mehr leere
mitinhaber und tinnitus wenn sie
irgendwo ab sondern sind die gut betreut
da bin ich sicher aber es ist einfach
nicht und er ist und das denke ich das
ist falsch
1999 simon bis 13
nach einem schwierigen jahr eröffnet
sich eine neue lösung
in aarau hatte ein dreiköpfiges lehrer
team eine privatschule gegründet
zugeschnitten auf simon eine schule die
von jedem schüler so viel verlangt wie
er leisten kann individual- unterricht
für die verschiedensten bedürfnisse
[Musik]
während simon mit dem ziel kosten
rechnet setzt sich der hochbegabte
sebastian mit komplexen aufgaben
auseinander
ein idealer ort um sich zu entwickeln
absolut die eigene initiative
[Musik]
simon macht in dieser zeit einen großen
schritt vorwärts
nach anfänglichem zögern stellt sich
auch die invalidenversicherung hinter
diese lösung und kommt für die kosten
der privatschule auf die sind viel
tiefer als in einer heilpädagogischen
sonderschule
[Musik]
2001 er ist 15
sein leben hat sich in den letzten zwei
jahren stabilisiert die privatschule
bietet ein ideales lernklima
[Musik]
inzwischen kann der lesen schreiben ist
vielseitig interessiert und hat sich
eine breite palette von hobbys zugelegt
auf diesen tag hat sich simon lange
gefreut
er bekommt ein eigenes mofa
hoch motiviert hatte die theoretische
prüfung bestanden
um sich seinen großen wunsch zu erfüllen
sie schienen der sinne hauptgrund sieht
dass er überhaupt dass er wirklich gar
nichts richtiges lesen und schreiben
das ist das gerade auf geordnet über das
jahr mit dem wirklich verkehrsregeln
kreiert die prüfungsfragen leser die
sitz verstaut gleichzeitig als dass ich
so von pädagogischen heißt das plus aber
das gilt ja wenn wenn er jetzt
aufgeklärt und wenn er die theoretisch
häufig uhr bestand hat die 2
[Musik]
noch hat er sein mofa nicht ganz im
griff
[Musik]
doch schon bald besteht auch die
praktische prüfung die komplexe aufgabe
des mofafahrers motiviert ihn für
weitere lärmschutz
im jahr 2002 wurde 16
[Musik]
die schulzeit geht langsam zu ende
als große herausforderung steht jetzt
die berufswahl an seine sporen verdient
simon auf einem bauernhof ab fast jeden
abend hilft er nach der schule im stall
aus er ist handwerklich begabt und
arbeitet gerne mit tieren für den
einstündigen einsatz bekommt ihr fünf
franken
ja
im jahr 2006 sehen wir uns wieder
vier jahre lang hatte ich keinen kontakt
mehr zu sehen
wir treffen uns im bahnhofbuffet wagen
hier könnte er sich einen kaffee bevor
er zur arbeit fährt
simon hat seinen traumjob bekommen im
zollino der kinder zur abteilung des
zürcher zoos erstaunt bin ich wie er
sich auf den weg zur arbeit macht
[Musik]
als das laufen und musiker mit nur einem
richtigem tobi der vorstand noch
überladen
pünktlich um 7 uhr kommt er im zollino
an sein morgenritual er begrüßt seine
lieblingstiere die beiden hausschweinen
db und burgi
[Musik]
nein
insgesamt drei jahre kann er insulin
arbeiten
er bekommt eine volontariat stelle diese
geht über in eine iv anlehre das heißt
der zoo bildet hinaus und die
invalidenversicherung kommt für seinen
lohn auf seit er volljährig ist bekommt
er 1800 franken für die iv ist das eine
günstige lösung
einmal mehr hat sion glück gehabt dass
sie an die richtigen leute geraten ist
[Musik]
das mit dem sie bemerkt hat das ist
immer schritt für schritt für sie und wo
genau das eigentlich gesagt haben wir
bis jetzt noch nicht also ich spüre das
potenzial unser wunsch und wo es
spannend ich zu merken dass gott dann
schritt für schritt weiter und
normalerweise ist
die uhr nachmittags wie jeden tag muss
er die ziegen in den stall locken
die arbeit mit den tieren erfüllt ihn
voll und ganz und seine vorgesetzten
sind zufrieden mit ihm
auch die gewerbeschule gehört zu seiner
ausbildung einmal in der woche besucht
er die berufsschule für tierpflege in
olten
er muss keine prüfungen ablegen für ihn
geht es darum möglichst viel
mitzubekommen
[Musik]
auch hier steht simon stundenweise ein
stück lehrer zur seite eine lehrkraft
die von der iv finanziert wird
ohne zu zögern hat sich die schulleitung
auf dieses experiment eingelassen lobby
hätten ihn unterricht das bezahlen
schneller oder vielleicht auch hin und
wieder einmal die spitze langsamer
organisieren
das macht das ganze nicht zum problem
also mit dem bekannten konnte dass das
funktioniert also ich bitte meine fans
im simon hilft beim raub sind beobachtet
dass saas anbieter kasse dann muss das
auch an einer berufsschule
möglich sei aber die würze einfach jetzt
als dogma aufstelle damals in der zeit
als musiker sondern von fall zu fall
mit meinen letzten verhältnis gut geht
der fall vom simon zeigt wie dank
integration menschen zurück in unsere
schulen zurück in unsere arbeitsprozesse
kommen
es gibt viele wie simon warum sehen wir
diese menschen kaum
warum sind sie nicht unter uns
[Musik]
und ich begrüße ganz verzichten sie
morgen doppel mir im studio in der
stadtgärtnerei und natürlichkeit ältere
dem gold unter peter federer kurz mittel
und das ist sieben jahre als ich den
film geschaut worden ist simon besteht
sozusagen über nacht zum fernsehstar
wurde ist das eine gute idee ist das
nutzer hat das eigentlich in richtung
furth chance endlich aufklären
ich hatte ja du hast das du hast nur
froh kamera um xx ist aber noch eine
straße titel remix erster vermisst man
kann ich noch nicht so gut wie es für
sie was hat sie für reaktionen auf den
film
also die meisten sind wirklich sexy
zeigt an dass das gold und dass sie das
unterstützen denn jetzt und die weiße
pracht irgendwo vielleicht geschrieben
hat oder nicht behindert schwarz haben
das ende ihrer ausführungen extrawurst
signum gar dass mir das gefühl nach der
hotellerie vorstellig und mehr handel
also ihre orchesters ich es nicht
gemacht haben und dass ich es für jedes
kind machen
ein vorteil ist sicher dass dieses
ehepaar sind sie immer noch fachlich
witzel mehr als andere wenn sie bei
behörden vorstellig werden etwas
vielleicht wird das gewicht aus als wenn
jetzt schäferhund hat das kreischen
vorteil für sie hat er begann sich also
ich hatte nie druck also im studium herr
m
eigentlich müsste also menschen sagt ein
zentrum auf dem hemd
wenn gemerkt dass uns das eigentlich
tabu was man klärt angeht und und ich
glaube der vorteil ist dass mit der
irgendwann gemerkt in der eigenwerbung
was und apparat eine eigene achse und
meinte sky experte geht wo wirklich bis
vista sp1 gerufen
widersprüchliche meinigen eigentlich und
und sind ganze hof sachzwang hält man es
im mixer oder sind und mehr in den
wendehammer der wahlkreis 82 1 geht es
nicht wenn sein
es war gut aber die 20 jahren sowie
termine seit abbruch addiert so dass
steht mit den programmen und und hat da
probiert und lösungen zu finden und
dafür kreativ sie aber zwischenstand
syndrom erforscht sie die orte und wenn
ja auch was mit 100 zu belangen dass man
das schon kennt ist trotzdem jede
biografie so einzigartig dass muss sagte
ja man muss jetzt man muss das rinnsal
erforscht das stimmt aber nicht mit
früheren ganz viel vorstand an syndrom
bis zum sommer verändert noch ein
interessierter seite und nicht merkt
dass man eigentlich nur weiß das ist für
mich auch glücklich stück weit dass das
immer so nicht nötig zu sein so viel
will und mich an der frau merkel eine
schon ganz wach und den ich ganz lang
und dann haben vielleicht aus beobachtet
und die liebe leid aber ich muss kommen
so müssten eigentlich so tat schwachen
gar nicht so lang und steinig spannend
wurde da haben wir beobachten mit war
wieder wach und mit war wieder lang das
so sensibel wenn ich zum beispiel
getankt ich weiß nicht weiter unter
druck
und das merken wir eine idee kann wieder
wieder auftaucht ist das wieder krieg
also simon tischer nach mexiko immer
gesagt ich will ob für die zeit wenn ich
heute noch ihre bescheide doch recht
gericht aber er gibt sich beschäftigt
bis erreichen oder meine malerei weil
ich finde dass ich und mache ich koche
ich diese aber natürlich wieder ganz
vorn im filmhof gehört oder 20 c bis
jetzt müssen wir derzeit 720 bereits
wochen arbeitet die honig der skoda yeti
richtig müssen abschied vom soffin kann
man sagen und jetzt lockt mit dem aber
vom simon vergangen ist
simon im element als barkeeper in einem
konzert lokal in baden im januar dieses
jahres
einmal pro woche arbeitete hier
nun bekommt er für diesen nebenjob
keinen aber zumindest das trinkgeld
dafür behalten
nach st
sein iphone ist immer zur stelle um
auszurechnen wie viel rückgeld ergeben
muss für das personal im kulturlokal ist
simon eine bereicherung
ich glaube das ganze team
wir haben uns lange nicht mehr gesehen
was hat sich in den letzten sieben
jahren alles getan womit verbringt er
seine zeit
simon hat mir viel zu erzählen tagsüber
arbeitet der 27-jährige jetzt als
schulhaus abfahrt in der privatschule
drive in aarau die er selber besuchte er
ist sich für keine arbeit zu schade wc
putzen gehört zu seinen
lieblingsbeschäftigungen
mit seiner chefin schulleiterin gabi
dubach bespricht der den arbeitsplan
simon hatte ein 70 prozent pensum der
organisationsaufwand mit ihm ist zwar
etwas größer
dafür zeigt dir eine vorbildliche
arbeitsmoral ständig der nicht seriös
entlastung ich muss mir nie hätte ich
muss wie kontrolliere ich weiß jetzt
wenn ihr gebot der auch das ist richtig
simon auf dem heimweg
er will mir seine wohnung zeigen seit
eineinhalb jahren wohnt er nicht mehr
bei seinen eltern in der altstadt von
baden hat er sein neues zuhause gefunden
stolz präsentiert er es mir seine
wohnung hatte er selber eingerichtet ich
bin beeindruckt wie selbstständig ihr
geworden ist hochreiter tun ich am
kochen und damit halb mache ich
eigentlich auch ihr gefällt werden
[Musik]
er wird abgeholt von lauff kollege
christian seit gut fünf jahren hat simon
ein neues hobby
das langstrecken laufen simon ist sogar
inoffizieller marathon weltrekordhalter
der läufer mit down syndrom
aktuell stecken die beiden wieder in den
vorbereitungen für einen großen lauf ein
paar tage später an diesem tag steht der
lysser marathon auf dem programm
auch mutter irmgard und vater peter
federer sind angereist um ihren sohn
moralisch zu unterstützen
simons ziel ist ehrgeizig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
verblüffend dass sich simon gerade für
diese sportart entschieden hat
langstrecken laufen erfordert viel
disziplin und durchhaltevermögen
es geht ja grundsätzlich anrufer hofer
forderte alle parteien sind rom um
intellektuell wasser und vor allem immer
vorstellen was sichere all das nicht
können und darum ist einfach spannend
jetzt sehen dass ich mir mit dem 7 und
hält sehen das aber die ganz viele
sachen aber aber plötzlich sache habe
seit das konzil und und das mit der
sportart dass stephen evans
das wetter ist gas durch das tempo tief
und simon nicht in topform
christian beschließt heute mit simon nur
den halbmarathon zu laufen
mit ein bisschen wollte
zwei stunden 45 minuten ist ihre
schlusszeit simon ist sichtlich
enttäuscht dass christian und er nach 21
kilometern aus strecken mussten
gerne hätte er den ganzen marathon
absolviert ich denke die zeit stand
heute nicht im vordergrund und das war
das ausschlaggebende dass wir dann
gesagt haben jetzt machen wir noch mal
schön schlusspurt und genießen den
zieleinlauf wenn noch leute da sind dann
das war schon schön
im elternhaus ist es ruhiger geworden
seid ihr eine eigene wohnung hat ein bis
zweimal pro woche kommt hier noch vorbei
also wenn er wenn es so läuft und so
dass schüssel anfänger verhängt und wenn
es nur gott liegt der wachmacher also
wie bei jedem hängt heute gibt es von
katar und früchtekuchen dabei kommen wir
auf simons neue freundin eine frau
ebenfalls mit down syndrom zu sprechen
er hat sie über facebook kennengelernt
mit der er ab ich mache so schön ich bin
nur django kino oder konzert
das macht er mit kers hobby rallye mega
früher die ja noch sehr jung diese
pärchen kleine
[Musik]
simon ist richtig vernünftig geworden
sein betätigungsfeld erscheint
vielfältig den lebensunterhalt vermag er
zum teil in silber zu bestreiten
nie hätte ich gedacht dass wir ihm so
viel möglich wird ich bin gespannt wie
es ein weg weitergeht
alles gute simon marathon ich muss sagen
da hat mit der kufe die wohnungs findet
dass wir für zeltweg sie selber
organisiert wissen das gar nicht nur in
ihren bauch hat wird im klartext für
kinder bietet unter flächig der nummer
der frau anita luther durch die wohnung
ich weiß jetzt auch ohne dass auf
organisiert noch bevor er ist dann
stimmen wir damit doch dann tronic mehr
beraters großartig maximal verteiler von
ihnen freundin lieber nicht so gut ich
war doch ich hab nicht reden aber wenn
wir wirklich retten rückschläge und die
hat sie sich wacker meine hand jetzt
geht das ist das ist ein film über als
erfolgsgeschichte eigentlich wie sie mit
rückschlägen und gang wer jetzt denkt
das ist schon schwierig stück sie
schwierigste für mich sie kommen nach
drei hat er noch zwei jahre wurde
schlagseite täter blieb aber die andere
durch spezielle
einzige messe nutze und der schöne
gegangen doch haben wir nicht schlucken
und dann quasi der stillstand oder gott
setzt indem sie das risiko gegangen also
mir gesagt hat
das machen wir nicht mit das aufgebot
niederschlag und den haben wir selber
brief das integrationsprojekt gemacht es
ist ein rückschlag sie wusste weder
öffentliche gegangen ist und nach eines
privat alles besser machen aber sich
nicht gegangen will sich so vorhang ihr
zu also mit dem der umschlag die anderen
und das ist wirklich ein schlauch fuß
ketzler rückschlag um simon meine
kritischen superman des aufsteigers oder
oder hitzköpfe geordnet was nicht mehr
hintereinander spiel wirkt also mir
hängt natürlich zwischen die plötzliche
bis nie gegangen aber mehrheit mehr in
dem er probiert zuckerwatte und das ist
nicht gut was gott der social sentry
begangen also mir internet irgendwann
die das klare ziel karton motocross
event mit dem klappt und wenn es nicht
gegangen ich sehen umfragen die karriere
sie sind psychiater diese sinnlos arzt
und sehr viel wissen sie über die
menschen vertrauen erhalten so das ist
irgendwie gurken
ihr habt jetzt filme aus 15 jahre meter
rang nicht wieder böse du mich jetzt
nicht mehr in seinem zimmer foto
roswitha und den kollegen diego
auftaucht und eis wie spezielle nummer
wie ein theater gemacht von 180 c a bit
of its cars im kinsky zwei jahren
gretzky als einziges mal hat
kindergarten hütet und heckseite simon
liegen am boden macht auch der schrank
geholt so ein paar stunden auf dem
bettlaken herrn ecclestone hat k4 bemüht
der studie von der schuldfrage
definierte schule und den habe ich aber
zählt nur dank der ote hatte die
heilpädagogisch kann mich so gut zur
gerät aber nicht plötzlich mit dem blitz
zu machen
minute und diverse konnten sie nicht ist
eher auf konter und hätte getanzt und so
sind sie nicht signal sie bei mir
bedankt hat eine idee hätte es so fest
dass sie verstärkt in der haut
aufgemacht
also ich wünsche ihnen und zwar sei es
jetzt aus team alles gute zukunft und
der speziell simon der seine zukunft
träumen die wünsche natürlich kennt
danke vielmals der wüste sind die
fortsetzung folgt ist ein anderes buch
kauft ein jugendlicher was ist aber
nicht im griff gehabt räder vor trinkaus
teenager und es mit 15 ist ein schweren
alkohol xii was ist aus dem krieg wurde
das auf die heutigen jungen
verantwortungsvolle erwachsene familie
hat und müssen uns natürlich wundern
wenn er den schritt geschafft hätte und
wie es überhaupt so weit
danke den fans zu fortsetzung folgt
[Musik]